Aaron Rodgers packs on the PDA with a  new girlfriend Danica Patrick she's  amazing the 34 year old Green Bay  Packers star was alongside his ladylove  during the Daytona 500 in Florida on  Sunday where he gave her a sweet smooch  before she hit the track I think that's  really cool  Danica recently confirmed the Daytona  race would be the final one of her  NASCAR career and posted to Instagram a  few snaps of the trip including one of  the NFL quarterback writing doing  Daytona with all the people that mean  the most to me along with a heart emoji  things sure seem to be heating up  between the pair but that doesn't mean  the 34 year old racecar driver is a fan  of her man's NFL team she told the AP in  January though she's dating Aaron and  will root for him as a player her NFL  allegiance will always lie with the  Chicago Bears I think it's pretty silly  you